alors avant de parler des dix
commandements vous avez sans doute
entendu dans la loge de ce que les
lâches seuils de 10 et est-ce qu'il ya
quelque chose qui vous choquent ou au
contraire vous pensez que non d'abord je
suis très admiratif de l'est la chine
parce que je trouve qu'elle a un sens
moyen terme d'image inspecteurs je
trouve que vous avez fait une interview
sans faute c'est à dire qu à vous
entendre on se demande vraiment et je le
dis avec toute la passion que j'ai pour
le peuple palestinien
on se demande comment pourquoi rabin est
mort parce qu'il a voulu faire la paix
on se demande pourquoi barak n'a pas
réussi à signer la paix avec arafat et
on se demande pourquoi shimon peres se
bat encore au quotidien pour que la paix
existe entre israéliens et palestiniens
je suis un peu ému parce que je trouve
que c'est une c'est ce qui se passe
entre autres ces deux pays est une
tragédie humaine
je vais faire juste à payer ça parce que
les gens ne connaissent pas l'histoire
de ces deux peuples en 47 après le
génocide on vous avait parlé tout à
l'heure très bien d'ailleurs en 47
il ya eu le partage de la palestine et
c'est les nations unies qui était à
l'époque 59 nation pas autant
qu'aujourd'hui qui ont décidé que deux
pays et des deux peuples vivraient en
palestine
d'un côté le peuple juif tout c'est
banni tous et mortifié de la terre et
ses essais trucider de ce conflit dead
qui a embrasé notre notre monde en 1940
et puis d'un autre côté ce peuple
palestinien dont c'était le pays et la
terre puisque les pères et les grands
pères de ces hommes là étaient sur place
et beaucoup pensé que c'était une bonne
chose pense au roi abdallah par exemple
à l'époque qui disaient que c'est
extraordinaire de voir ce peuple sémite
ce peuple juif revenir vers les siens
pour nous aider à construire les états
unis du
du crash rien non et puis il faut
essayer de faire parce que je vais
parler du passé puis je vais très vite
aller sur l'avenir et les palestiniens
ont refusé d'emblée ce se soit posé un
étapes ensemble et pas deux états c'est
pas que je continue
ensuite il ya eu malheureusement je
dirais dans cette première guerre entre
les juifs et la palestine
beaucoup de grands leaders palestiniens
sont morts d hommes qui étaient qui
avaient des âmes nobles âmes fier et
âmes neuves qui étaient ces grands
hommes musulmans arabes qui voulaient
porter la nation vers quelque chose de
fort et je cherche ainsi si ces hommes
là si certains de ces hommes là était
restée parmi nous la paix règne
aujourd'hui au proche orient
et puis il ya eu tout ce qu'on sait je
pas refaire l'histoire mais quand même
il est quand même oreille spontanée eu
quand même la proposition barak
il ya eu quand même l'acceptation de 2,2
de cet homme qui était élu des
israéliens qui est venu vers les
patients vers vers arafat qui est venu
vers lui en disant d'accord on est
d'accord pour tous quand est-ce qu'on
commence barak est venu il a dit hey
daddy arafat mais prenez cette paix on
la veut on vous donne une partie de
jérusalem puis leur sort il ne l'a
jamais refusé mais il n'a jamais signé
mais il n'a jamais refusé ils étaient
près on n'était pas arrivé à des
conclusions sur toutes les questions
qu'il fallait discuter on était prêt à
continuer sauf que barack son peuple l'a
fait tomber son gouvernement il était
plus premier gel palais kovalev toile
j'ai pas la seule cette conversation
parce que j'ai des arguments qui sont
inverses donc je vais vraiment pensé que
je veux aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je
n'en peux plus on n'en pouvons plus
le monde n'en peut plus de voir que les
enfants il ya des gosses qui au lieu
d'être avec leur mère lancé des cailloux
sur des tanks qui y adhèrent
non mais madame je veux y ait des mères
juives qui pleurent leurs enfants comme
les maires palestiniens perdent peuple
heures les leurs moi je veux dire vous
avez le raid a fait évidemment vous êtes
sa représentante ici et il a pas besoin
de vous parce que dans les dix dernières
années vous par les médias vous avez
fait un travail remarquable
vous avez été vraiment le prophète de la
palestine en france puisqu'il avait re
vous avez réussi à retourner totalement
l'opinion française et je vous tire mon
chapeau
donc si vous voulez c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui dit arafat qui met toute
son énergie même avec son téléphone
portable uniquement pour essayer de
calmer le hamas et que peut-être ce
moment-là sharon calmera les colons
éclats et que et qu'à ce moment là
madame qu'il a et lui pour une fois pour
une fois qu'ils sortent en disant voilà
c'est moi aujourd'hui c'est pas
l'israélien qui dit fois sont venus vers
moi mais c'est moi aujourd'hui qui va
les israéliens et qui leur dit je veux
la paix ici et maintenant comme il est
dit dans dans nos livres commun ici et
maintenant je vous promets que je le
dirai au président
et ils ont acquis
vous reprenez volontiers à votre compte
cette phrase d'andré chouraqui qui dieu
c'est à étudier tous les livres si les
hommes suivaient les dix commandements
et vivra en paix absolument
une série je me suis amusé à quelque
chose avec andré justement jeudi andré
et sion d'ajouter un commandement otan
retranché 1 et ont sans tenir compte
c'est impossible y en a cinq qui
concerne le dieu 5 qui concerne notre
vie quotidienne oui tu ne trompera pas
et puis les autres c'est tu respectes
une aura qu'un dieu etc
mais c'est vrai qui résume notre
existence sociale et religieuse au
quotidien et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
revient à notre notre discussion si les
palestiniens israéliens et les peuples
arabes en général et les peuples de la
bible du coran et du nouveau testament
respecter ses commandements là on
vivrait en se demandant à quelle heure
on déjeune ensemble alors vous dites
vous je suis un femme de moïse c'est le
seul homme à avoir dialogué avec dieu
est-ce que 1 de la morandais est ce que
pour les chrétiens pour les catholiques
est-ce que moïse a la même importance
que pour les juifs non bien sûr puisque
l'importance principal et il l'a nommé
j'en étais heureuse c'est jésus christ à
attirer les musulmans mais donc de ce
côté là on reconnaît que vous êtes nos
ancêtres vous êtes nos aïeux nous
dépendons de vous si le parkinson
véritable clavier pape a dit les juifs
sont les frères aînés de
l'église oui mais pire pillon jeu dans
les régions comme la prophète bien
juillet de nay et cherchent tous à
moussa présidera au jugement dernier
j'ai rencontré une femme à new york je
suis très américaine en ce moment qui
m'a dit c'était une la femme d'un
banquier et les libanaises d'obédience
musulmane et elle m'a dit j'étais très
inquiète parce que ils ont mis mon mari
à la tête d'une banque à new york et les
principaux clients d'une banque à new
york c'est les juifs
elle m'a dit on va se faire la malle est
arrivé à nuire aux et on va se faire
vraiment la mini et elle m'a dit mais ce
sont mes soeurs on a la même approche de
la famille
on a la même approche oui pour les
enfants elle m'a dit mais on aimait
qu'on est comme ça ce sont mes meilleurs
amis et j'ai découvert ça à new york a
ajouté la palestine ce qu'on aime
beaucoup plus proche qui est un peu la
sienne suédois préfecture
alors andré chouraqui toujours lui a dit
moïse comme jésus comme mahomet sont en
fait les fils préféré de dieu ah oui
bien sûr bien sûr ce sont des ce sont
des portes c'est mon nom mais j'écoute
est l'intérêt d'un dialogue c'est chacun
son identité bien surtout pour nous
jésus est fils de dieu et donc l'égal de
dieu c'est le messie fils de dieu je ne
peux pas enlever ça où je perds ma
radicalité identitaire et c'est le coeur
de notre foi parce que si les papes fils
de dieu la résurrection n'existe pas
et là je suis bien obligé de l'affirmer
vis-à-vis des musulmans comme des juifs
moi je respecte
c'est mon genre esprit je respecte
toutes les tous les désirs du vent qui
sont des désirs de paix au travers de
quelle quelle que soit les phrases qu'on
qu'on utilise alors vous avez fait un
spectacle en fait les dix commandements
qui re qui regroupe en fait ce qu'ont en
commun les grandes religions
monothéistes
ça vous est venu comment cette idée
j'avais je cherchais pour le neutre le
de la fin du millénaire où je cherchais
une idée et l'idée des dix commandements
est venue et j'ai dit mais où il faut
faire un spectacle avec les dix
commandements
moi je n'ai jamais fait le spectacle en
lui-même jamais fait théâtre et gégé
j'ai eu ce sentiment qu'il fallait faire
ça et qu'il fallait le faire là
maintenant vous êtes croyant vous oui et
puis vous y croyez en est obligatoire en
croyant puisque on croit en soi
donc on croit en dieu puisque 100 sans
l'autre sens leila shahid je ne peux pas
croire à la paix puisque maintenant elle
va essayer de parler à un fade
donc si vous voulez je suis croyant
les corrections de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus